[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas la federación
rusa es un país de escarpados contrastes
por un lado la inmensa mayoría de sus
casi 150 millones de habitantes viven en
la pobreza pero por otro es uno de los
países con más influencia internacional
la madre rusia sigue siendo toda una
superpotencia influencia que claro está
no proviene de su poder económico y es
que eso economía representa menos del 2%
del pib mundial no tiene empresas
demasiado relevantes a nivel global y
para colmo su evolución económica
durante los últimos años ha sido
bastante negativa desde luego no es en
la economía donde russian que la su
influencia política sino
fundamentalmente en su poder militar
aunque cada vez más lejos de eeuu rusia
sigue siendo considerada como la segunda
gran potencia militar y hoy por hoy tan
solo china amenaza con hacerla
retroceder un puesto en el ranking
mundial el ejército ruso cuenta con
aproximadamente 900 mil soldados en
activo y 2 millones en la reserva una
cifra que si bien se ha visto
considerablemente reducida con el paso
de los años sobre todo si tenemos en
cuenta la referencia de los más de 4
millones de soldados en activo
a la unión soviética- siga estando
respaldada por el mayor arsenal de armas
nucleares de todo el mundo y alguno de
los misiles intercontinentales más
avanzados que existen porque rusia es
ante todo un país forjado en torno a su
arsenal nuclear y sus fuerzas armadas
para que os hagáis una idea los cálculos
existentes apuntan a que este país
mantiene aún hoy un arsenal de casi
6.500 armas nucleares
[Música]
pero amigos amigas de visual político
como tantas veces ocurre y los números
pueden convertirse en toda una trampa y
en el caso del ejército ruso pasa algo
de eso
[Música]
y es que veréis aunque las cifras en
torno a las dimensiones de sus fuerzas
armadas son asombrosas los rusos tienen
un enorme problema la antigüedad de
muchas de sus armas tanques submarinos y
demás artefactos en condiciones de lucha
abierta si tuviésemos que enfrentar a
eeuu con rusia el país de putin no
tendría bastante complicado ahora bien
esto es algo que durante los últimos
años se ha convertido en toda una
obsesión para moscú entre otras cosas
porque la industria militar rusa es muy
pero que muy importante para el país
para el país y por supuesto para el
bolsillo de muchos de sus políticos que
bueno ya sabéis cómo funcionan las cosas
por estos lares el caso es que la
industria militar rusa la segunda más
importante tras la de eeuu que es
responsable de algo más de 2 millones de
empleos lo que representa ni más ni
menos que el 3 por ciento de toda la
fuerza laboral y el 20 por ciento de
todos los empleos industriales del país
vamos que exceptuando las materias
primas la industria militar es una de
las principales actividades económicas
de la federación rusa además de una
importante baza de las relaciones
internacionales precisamente por eso en
este vídeo os vamos a contar cómo es en
realidad el ejército ruso y también
cuáles son los planes que moscú ha
puesto en marcha para tratar de
consolidarse como la segunda potencia
militar incluso
encima de china os venís con nosotros a
descubrir una parte más fuerte y a la
vez más débil de la madre rusia pues
arranquemos
[Música]
la gran vergüenza antes de empezar a
hablar sobre los viejos que son muchos
de los equipamientos militares de rusia
cosa que por otra parte estoy seguro que
en cierto modo todos sabéis hicimos un
poco la vista atrás para conocer el
origen de toda esta historia tenemos que
remontarnos hasta los años de la unión
soviética amigos la urss la unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas fue
durante toda su existencia un país muy
pobre un país muy pobre pero con un
enorme tejido industrial un tejido
industrial que ojo al dato en todo
momento estuvo preparado para la guerra
para que os hagáis una idea todas las
fábricas soviéticas tenían planes de
contingencia para producir armas y
equipos militares en caso de ser
necesario y es que como todos sabéis
durante toda su existencia la unión
soviética de la urss se dirigió bajo una
economía de guerra
[Aplausos]
por ejemplo un dato en el momento de su
caída del gigante soviético contaba con
4000 instalaciones de producción e
investigación militar e instalaciones
que empleaban a 6 millones de personas y
consumían atentos casi el 50 por ciento
de todo el presupuesto del estado
central si lo habéis escuchado bien el
50 por ciento de todo el presupuesto
toda una economía de guerra un sistema
económico preparado no para el bienestar
de sus ciudadanos sino para tratar de
aniquilar llegado el caso a cualquier
adversario sin embargo más de la mitad
de este enorme tejido industrial se
perdió tuvo que echarle el cierre
durante la gran crisis que se generó
tras la desintegración de la urss una
crisis en la que rusia perdió en torno
al 20 por ciento de su pib tan sólo
entre 1991 y 1993
[Música]
la crisis fue tan grave y tuvo tantas
repercusiones que la federación rusa no
logró recuperar el pib que tenía durante
la época de la unión soviética hasta el
año 2004 y por el camino su industria
militar sufre una especie de apocalipsis
casi el 70% de las empresas militares
desaparecieron y el sector perdió más de
3 millones y medio de empleos el 60 por
ciento de su fuerza laboral y eso eso no
es todo además buena parte de los
centros de producción quedaron fuera de
rusia en países que tras la
desintegración pasaron a ser
completamente independientes países como
por ejemplo ucrania que aglutinaba el 15
por ciento de toda la producción
industrial soviética de hecho de este
último elemento ha sido clave toda una
prioridad en la política exterior de
rusia veréis me explico el complejo
industrial-militar estaba fragmentado a
lo largo de toda la geografía soviética
la interdependencia económica en este
aspecto era sencillamente enorme de tal
forma que cuando se rompe la urss rusia
se enfrenta a un doble problema por un
lado como os hemos dicho la crisis
debilitó considerablemente su capacidad
industrial y por otro sus empresas de
producción militar y su ejército
dependían en buena medida de
funcionamientos tecnología y equipos que
ahora estaban en manos de otros países y
esto esto es lo que explica en buena
medida el empecinamiento que rusia ha
tenido por mantener un férreo control
sobre algunas de las ex repúblicas
soviéticas ex repúblicas como por
ejemplo ucrania pero sigamos nuevos
ejércitos necesitan una constante
inversión para mantenernos al día sin
embargo tras la caída de la unión
soviética revisa simplemente pues no
tenía dinero esto es lo que explica que
en 1998 el gasto militar ruso fuese un
tercio del de 1992 es decir pasó de unos
48.000 millones de dólares a poco más de
16.000 y evidentemente como os podéis
imaginar esta enorme reducción
presupuestaria vino acompañada del
hundimiento en la producción militar ojo
atentos a este dato a finales de los 90
la producción militar rusa suponía
apenas un 10% de lo que se producía en
1991 sí sí un 10 por ciento vaya a ruina
pero amigos espera un momento porque
todo comenzó a cambiar con la llegada
del nuevo milenio del nuevo milenio y de
uno de los grandes protagonistas de la
política internacional durante las
últimas dos décadas me estoy refiriendo
como no a vladimir putin al que algunos
denominan ya como el nuevo
de la madre rusia
y
el caso es que cuando putin llegó al
poder se encontró en lo que respecta a
las fuerzas armadas rusas con una
situación catastrófica apenas el 20 por
ciento de los equipos militares eran
relativamente recientes es decir
funcionales y no sólo eso sino que su
capacidad de reacción y despliegue
estaban por los suelos problemas que por
cierto en muchos casos hoy para existe
fijaos por ejemplo lo que ocurre con los
portaaviones mientras que a principios
del siglo 21 eeuu mantenía una flota de
14 de estos barcos repartidos pues por
todo el mundo
rusia apenas contaba con uno que encima
pues no era gran cosa
[Música]
se trata del admiral kutnetsov un
portaaviones de la etapa final de la
unión soviética con tecnología de
principios de los 80 pero que por
diversas carencias no estuvo 100%
operativo hasta 1998 pero este este no
es el único ejemplo que podemos
encontrar de como el ejército ruso
siempre ha presentado mejores números
que en realidad es otro caso lo podemos
encontrar en su inventario de tanques y
es que veréis aparentemente rusia tiene
la mayor flota de tanques de todo el
mundo hablamos según los cálculos
existentes de entre 15.000 y 20.000
unidades una cantidad incluso superior a
la de todos los países de la otan juntos
y cuál es el problema pues que la
mayoría de ellos son viejos muy viejos
rusia sigue operando antiguos tanques
soviéticos que datan de los años 60 y 70
[Música]
como veis un montón de puntos débiles
skin de otras cosas tuvieron serias
implicaciones durante la guerra bueno o
mejor dicho el ataque a georgia en 2008
fijaos
la guerra de georgia fue la primera
guerra abierta de rusia tras la caída de
la unión soviética y de alguna manera
sirvió para poner a prueba la eficacia
de su armamento y las capacidades de su
ejército y lo cierto es que no pasaron
la prueba se manifestaron todo tipo de
problemas falta de coordinación entre
los mandos militares ausencia de
armamento de precisión un mal
mantenimiento de los equipos militares y
una mala instrucción del personal algo
que hizo que a pesar de su enorme
superioridad su avance fuese lento y el
ejército ruso registrase mucho más
problemas y muchas más bajas de las que
había estimado todo esto supuso un
enorme dolor de cabeza para moscú que de
repente se dio de bruces contra una
realidad sus fuerzas armadas no se
correspondían con las de una gran
superpotencia
[Música]
y es que vamos a ver pensarlo un momento
si la invasión de un pequeño país como
georgia que ni siquiera se molestó mucho
en resistir se convirtió en una
constante sucesión de errores y
problemas de todo tipo que podría pasar
en caso de una operación de mucha mayor
envergadura os imagináis qué hubiese
ocurrido si el enfrentamiento hubiese
sido con tropas de la otan
[Música]
pues exactamente esa fue la pregunta que
se hicieron en moscú y la respuesta
pudimos verla poco después en 2011
cuando vladimir putin presentó un
completo programa integral para
modernizar las fuerzas armadas rusas un
objetivo que pasó a convertirse en la
gran prioridad nacional hablamos del
conocido como programa sap un programa
que contemplaba una gigantesca inversión
de hasta 650 mil millones de dólares
para comprar y desarrollar nuevos
aviones tanques y sobre todo submarinos
cohetes y misiles muchos misiles todo
con el objetivo de que para el año 2020
al menos el 70 por ciento de sus
sistemas militares pudieran considerarse
avanzados y plenamente operativos un
momento ya estamos en el 2020 entonces
qué resultados ha tenido este plan ha
mejorado sustancialmente el ejército
ruso en estos años pues bien veámoslo
una gran piedra en el camino a ver si ha
existido un evento que ha marcado
trastocado el plan de modernización del
ejército ruso y se ha sido claramente la
guerra de ucrania y la anexión de crimea
como ya os hemos contado en alguna que
otra ocasión esta acción militar le
costó a rusia duras sanciones de eeuu y
muchos otros países occidentales
sanciones que pusieron especialmente en
la diana a la industria militar rusa
además el hecho de que el gobierno
ucraniano ha surgido de la broma edad
enemigo de rusia lograse perdurar ha
hecho que moscú perdiera el acceso
directo a algunos de sus principales
proveedores militares fijaos
por ejemplo el fabricante de aviones
antonov ahora una empresa estatal
ucraniana tenía acuerdos con el
ministerio de defensa ruso para dotarles
de nuevos aviones de transporte militar
antonov 70 y antonov 124 también estaban
en marcha importantes contratos de
suministro de motores para nuevos
aviones y helicópteros de las rusas 1000
y cam off así como para algunos ya
colette por otra parte algunos contratos
importantísimos para el suministro de
componentes y tecnología para el
programa de modernización de fragatas
rusas también se hicieron añicos
trastocando seriamente los planes de
moscú el mayor ejemplo lo encontramos en
el fabricante de las nuevas fragatas de
clase almirante grigoróvich cuyas
turbinas de gas eran fabricadas por la
empresa ucraniana soria + project
[Música]
pues bien tal y como seguramente os
estáis imaginando todos estos contratos
fueron suspendidos por el gobierno
ucraniano tras la invasión lo que obligó
a rusia a tener que buscarse la vida
buscando a otros proveedores locales o
de países afines algo que no resulta tan
sencillo ni por el nivel de desarrollo
ni por el acoplamiento y la
compatibilidad tecnológica
y eso bueno eso no es todo además tras
los sucesos de ucrania y las acciones
internacionales y eeuu y muchos países
aliados detuvieron la venta de
componentes electrónicos de doble uso
civil y militar y de cristales y aceros
especiales que eran utilizados para
fabricar armas y satélites y los que
moscú se gastaba unos 500 millones de
dólares cada año es decir las sanciones
le causaron nada moscú todo un
galimatías pero dicho esto venga
centrémonos ya en resultados y sistemas
de armas pues bien a pesar de los
enormes esfuerzos realizados lo cierto
es que los problemas aún persisten y
según se calcula ha llegado el 2020
menos del 50 por ciento de las fuerzas
terrestres pues pueden considerarse
modernas fijaos por ejemplo en lo que
ocurrió con los tanques rusos de 14 arma
está la joya de la corona y uno de los
pasos considerados clave para modernizar
sus fuerzas terrestres pues bien
inicialmente rusia planeaba equiparse
con 2300 unidades de estos tanques hasta
el 2025 sin embargo el presupuesto se ha
diluido tanto que al final estos dos mil
trecientos tanques se han quedado en 132
y es que si antes os hablábamos de
crisis post soviética ahora rusia se
encuentra también inmersa en una doble
crisis una económica y monetaria por
ejemplo el rublo se ha devaluado frente
al dólar un 60 por ciento durante la
última década y otra diplomática que
como también os hemos contado ha
restringido enormemente el acceso de
rusia a mercados clave para modernizar
su sector militar
[Música]
a pesar de todo amigos y de no haberse
cumplido los objetivos lo cierto es que
el periodo 2011-2020 ha sido la etapa de
mayor modernización militar desde que
cayó la unión soviética
[Música]
durante este tiempo hemos visto como las
fuerzas aéreas rusas han incorporado
casi 100 su co y su 35 su caza más
avanzado con especificaciones muy
próximas a los cazas americanos y
europeos más recientes además se están
actualizando los viejos bombarderos
soviéticos con capacidad nuclear los
tupolev 160 para crear una nueva
variante de la que rusia busca
incorporar 10 unidades
el tupolev 160 m luego por el lado
marino que es donde más flaquean los
rusos y el programa ha dado prioridad a
los submarinos con capacidad nuclear
clase borei unos submarinos con 16
lanzadores de misiles que tienen
capacidad para aportar 6 cabezas
nucleares cada uno amigos el coste de
construir equipar y armar cada uno de
estos submarinos se acerca ni más ni
menos que a los mil millones de dólares
son la nueva joya de la corona del
arsenal ruso y por cierto en el momento
de preparar este vídeo ya hay cuatro
surcando los mares y así podríamos
continuar con muchos más equipos
[Música]
como veis el programa sap no se ha
completado pero a pesar de ello es
innegable el salto que ha supuesto para
las fuerzas armadas rusas pero dicho
esto hay una cuestión clave que puede
condicionar el futuro de todos estos
planes me refiero la capacidad militar
de un ejército tiene obviamente mucho
que ver con su capacidad industrial y
hoy en día para países como rusia su
influencia internacional está
directamente ligada a su capacidad para
fabricar y vender equipos militares
modernos más aún si tenemos en cuenta
que el país atraviesa una crisis
económica estructural pues bien la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es dónde
está el verdadero problema de la
industria militar rusa pues amigos sobre
todo en su enorme ineficiencia
la industria militar rusa es ante todo
una industria controlada y dirigida por
el estado y eso eso está ocasionando
muchos problemas como por ejemplo un
lento desarrollo tecnológico lo que no
solo le puede dejar atrás respecto a
eeuu sino también respecto a china pero
queréis un ejemplo de lo que estamos
hablando pues fijaos en el caso de la
empresa militar rusa rostec puesto que
es una empresa que factura algo más de
25 mil millones de dólares y que cuenta
con 529 mil empleados frente a ella la
estadounidense lockheed martin tiene 105
mil empleados cinco veces menos a pesar
de lo cual genera más de 53 mil 700
millones de dólares en ingresos es decir
casi el doble
pero puede que os estáis preguntando
pero enrique realmente eso esto es algo
tan importante
[Música]
pues digamos amigos que es una especie
de señal las empresas rusas son enormes
corporaciones muy burocráticas y pesadas
que además tienen la misión no solo de
desarrollar equipos militares sino
también como toda empresa pública de
tratar de contratar a todo hijo de
vecino y sea su lentitud le sumamos que
sus recursos son escasos porque
imaginaos lo que es pagar a tanta gente
evidentemente su capacidad para retener
a los mejores talentos es más bien
pequeña y eso eso genera un gap
tecnológico muy pero que muy importante
pensar que el mercado de las armas no es
muy diferente a cualquier otra actividad
la competitividad y la innovación
resultan claves pues bien el caso es que
estos problemas y el fracaso parcial del
plan 2011-2020 es lo que ha llevado al
mismísimo putin a anunciar un nuevo plan
con un presupuesto casi idéntico el plan
de armamento del estado 2018 2027 claro
que a diferencia del programa del 2011
hoy los recursos del estado ruso son
mucho pero que mucho más limitados
[Música]
en fin como veis durante la etapa de
vladimir putin al frente de rusia las
fuerzas armadas han experimentado un
enorme salto sin embargo aún hoy siguen
teniendo tres grandes problemas primero
en gran medida siguen estando
desactualizadas y mal equipadas más allá
de los grandes programas que el gobierno
ruso promociona a bombo y platillo en la
realidad los avances pues no son tantos
segundo la industria militar rusa sigue
siendo poco eficiente muy burocrática y
muy pesada lo que ya no sólo le supone
un reto a la hora de competir con las
empresas militares norteamericanas sino
también con nuevos jugadores como china
y tercero la crisis económica
estructural que vive el país plantea
serias dudas sobre su capacidad para
financiar la actualización y la
operatividad de sus fuerzas armadas con
todo es evidente que los esfuerzos del
gobierno de vladímir putin han hecho que
rusia mantenga su estatus como
superpotencia algo que por cierto a
finales de los 90 estaba en serias dudas
pero ahora ahora turno para ti
crees que rusia es un país tan fuerte y
temible y como nos hace creer la
propaganda de moscú déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a visar polític si aún no lo
has hecho una vez más muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]